bon actuellement
apparemment on n'est pas les plus mal
placés au point de vue beau vaccination
et puis l'organisation générale enfin
bon ça me choque pas particulièrement
qua non pour moi ça a été bien gérée
bah ils ont sauvé le chômage en france
le chômage partiel ça a été un des plus
généreux
qu'on ait vu en europe je pense si c'est
pas le but est le plus généreux donc non
je pense qu'ils ont bien géré la
situation le fasse à lithaire sa pente
ces résultats les gens sont plutôt
d'accord moi ça m'a bien oui bien sûr il
doit il doit rendre des comptes
effectivement oui on sait pas où on va
on sait pas ce qui s'est passé pendant
plus d'un an donc oui il faut que faut
qu'il y ait des réponses là je trouve
qu'ils ont très bien géré la crise
sanitaire
pas tout le monde est parfait il n'était
pas habitué aussi à gérer une crise
comme celle là et je pense par rapport
avec les moyens qu'ils ont eu
je pense qu'ils ont réagi assez
rapidement je pense qu'ils ont pris
quand même des actions même si ce n'est
pas toujours les bonnes et je trouve
qu'en fin de compte on s'en sort très
bien par rapport à d'autres pays aussi
le gouvernement à ses responsabilités il
doit oui tout à fait il doit doit
répondre de ses actes et la crise
sanitaire doit l'assumer jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya plein de
monde c'est comme si on était bon et est
revenu au point de départ en fait le
télétravail n'existe pas ce matin j'ai
pris les transports c'était blindé les
genres et les gens portent plus masquer
donc c'est comme c'était oublié mais
c'est comme ça il faut
malheureusement on n'a pas notre mot à
dire on est des petits
on abat échelle on abat et chaîne non
non je pense que c'est un peu excessif
le gouvernement
non seulement je trouve que pour une
crise aussi
imprévisible que celle là je pense que
l'on
s'est relativement bien géré et non
seulement ça je pense et il ya des
réponses politiques 1 c'est pas devant
la justice que ça se passe ce genre de
choses moi je pense que le gouvernement
doit rendre des comptes au niveau de la
justice ça a été très très mal géré et
puis voilà on en a marre de tout ça un
coup ils ouvrent ils ouvrent les restos
accueille les fermes
ils peuvent pas fermer une bonne qui
ferme tout pendant un certain moment et
puis ça ira mieux enfin faut pas ouvrir
fermer ouvrir fermer par voilà